[Music]
hello everyone today we're going to talk
about AWS in 10 minutes let's look at
the agenda here let's talk about what
AWS is why it's such a big hit we'll
have a look at the overview of the
services we'll see how much it costs how
big it is and what the future of AWS is
so what is AWS everyone is talking about
Amazon Web Services but let's have a
look at what it is it's basically a
global cloud platform which allows you
to host and manages services on the
Internet
it's used by almost 80% of Fortune 500
companies to host their infrastructure
and it has a lot of services which it
provides to its customers there's
infrastructure service which means they
provide fair servers as a service so you
don't need to manage the backup and the
power supply of the service they provide
platform of the service you can get Java
Ruby PHP as a service so that you don't
have to manage the binaries of these
applications you get software as a
service where and you get email sending
capabilities like SES you get queuing
services like sqs and it's a cloud
storage platform where and you have a
lot of storage options including EBS and
s3 so all in all AWS is a hosting
provider which gives you a lot of
services wherein you can run your
applications on the cloud now let's take
a look at why it's such a big hit so
everyone is trying to use AWS everyone
is trying to put their applications on
the cloud so what's the reason that AWS
is the top provider and the top choice
for doing anything on the cloud one of
the biggest reasons is the billing so
the billing is very clear you get a per
hour billing every instance or every
service has a micro billing so be it
instances on ec2 you get per hour
billing rate which is very transparent
even s3 buckets are charged on a per GB
basis although it is a storage service
but still there is micro billing
available there the signup process is
easy you don't need to sign any
agreement nothing you just go sign up
with an email id add a credit card and
you're good to go you can go from zero
to 100 in just two minutes you can
launch your servers big machines without
buying hardware without procuring any
hardware you can just be up and running
in minutes so they're billing dashboard
is also very simple they give you an
integrated billing dashboard which gives
you reports you can pull out reports
every month you can pull out reports
based on services based on various
parameters for the cloud provider to be
a hit you need it to be stable it has to
be a trusted thing so their services are
quite stable in the last seven or eight
years they have seen some three or four
major outages but those have been only
region specific so that means out of the
12 or 13 regions in which they operate
the outages have been region specific in
a particular country or continent and
those also have not been more than two
or three hours and have not affected all
of their customers it's a trusted vendor
so when we talk about AWS it comes up
with something which is used by everyone
in the industry from small startups to
big enterprises everyone sees Amazon as
a trusted adviser now let's have an
overview of the most commonly used
services so the first and the most
commonly used service is EC 2 which is
Elastic Compute cloud this is the
service which gives you bare servers so
this service will give you a machine
which you can launch and you can run
your software on those you can get small
or big machines based on your
requirements
the second choice is VPC so Amazon will
not allow you full control of their
cloud instead they give you chunks of
their cloud which is VPC or the virtual
private cloud so VPC lets you create
networks in the cloud and then run your
servers in those networks the next one
is s3 which is simple storage service so
s3 gives you the opportunity to upload
and share files so does mostly a file
storage and sharing service then you've
got RDS which is relational database
service
so this RDS allows you to run and manage
databases on the cloud so they've got
almost all the major flavors of
databases right from SQL Server to
Oracle and MySQL PostgreSQL they have
recently launched another one which is
called aurora which claims to be a very
high-performance database then route 53
is therefore dns so they've got a
managed DNS service where and you can
point your dns to Amazon and they take
care of the stuff so it's a global DNS
service it's a scalable DNS service so
it scales according to demand there's
also elastic load balancer the ELB is a
service which gives you the opportunity
to load balanced incoming traffic to
multiple machines so this way you can
scale up your web applications to any
number of users
you've got auto scaling which adds
capacity on-the-fly to elastic load
balancers so that your website or your
application is never down due to a load
how much does it cost this per hour
billing is already mentioned for
everything if it's something like a
storage thing again there's a per hour
or per GB month storage so I think there
is region specific pricing so Virginia
is the cheapest region out of all of
them so the region specific pricing is
because they have got some regions which
they have got good hold of and they are
the headquarters so Oregon and Virginia
are the cheapest actually
they also give you services based on the
term so if you sign up for something for
a year it would be cheaper for you
rather than signing up for something on
an on-demand basis so they've got
reserved instances which are very cheap
as compared to the on-demand ones you
can get discounts from 20% to almost 60%
if you sign up for a three-year term
they are spot resources examples of
these are spot instances so this is like
a bidding market base where you can bid
for a price the only downside of this
kind of pricing is that your machine
might be terminated or your resources
might be terminated if someone bids
higher people use these kind of things
for doing some ad hoc in search or some
ad hoc tasks which are really not
critical how big is it they have got 15
regions across two major countries of
the world
they've got regions in the US Europe
Asia Pacific they've got a global
footprint so in today's world if you are
anywhere in the world you would have a
region within 1,000 miles of your
location
they've got massive data centers so each
of the region has got multiple
availability zones so one availability
zone can be thought of as a big data
center the data centers have anywhere
from 300,000 to 500,000 servers what is
the future of AWS so they currently have
64 services which span across
infrastructural service software as a
service platform as a service they are
launching new services in all demands
every day right now they are focusing on
machine learning so recently they've
launched a couple of services which
focus exclusively on machine learning
and they are focusing on software as a
service product wherein they want to
take control of the service you want to
utilize they don't want you to do it
they want you to upload it to them and
every now and then they keep on reducing
the costs so you would hear it in the
blog that okay the price of ec2 machines
has been reduced
and this is because of their scale so
they scale up and they give the
cost-benefit to the customer that's all
for today guys with just a quick intro
of the Amazon Web Services cloud hey
once become an expert in cloud computing
then subscribe to simpler Channel and
click here to watch more such videos
turn it up and get certified in cloud
computing click here